you are very critical of post-modernism
and the egalitarian wave of the 60s
isn't there a danger of throwing the
baby out with the bathwater are there
positive things about these movements at
the moment no not really I don't think
there's much positive about them at all
I think they've gone way too far
I think they dominate the humanities the
post-modernism meaning the fact that the
post modernists point is that there is a
very large number of ways to interpret
any closed set of phenomena something
like that any limited set of phenomena
and that's true but it's it's shallow
it's very very shallow dr. and and if if
I'm throwing the baby out with the
bathwater then it's a baby that needs to
be thrown out and afraid are the
positive things about these movements
not at the moment right I can't see
anything positive about it I think it's
it's degenerated into a ideological
claptrap and I think it's destroying the
universities so the egalitarian wave of
the 60s that's a different issue I would
say I mean I mean I don't think it's
reasonable to deny the utility of the
civil rights movement in the 1960s for
example and or and you know there were
movements before that like the labor
movement that had real justification for
being it isn't that everything that
always happens on the left is bad I
don't think that at all I think that the
people who are let's say on the lower
end of the economic distribution need a
powerful voice in politics I think
that's only fair and I mean there is
room for an egalitarian oriented ethos
but that isn't what equity is this has
become completely ideological and
there's just no there's just no excuse
for it as far as I'm concerned